Hello,
and welcome.
Hello, Taylor. How are you?
Doing alright. How about yourself, David?
Yeah. I'm very well. Thank you. It is
getting towards the end of my day, so
it's
a nice way to end the day with
a nice look at Kubernetes and spend some
time with yourself. How are you today?
Doing well. It's yeah. Just just kicking off
my day personally here. So I promise I
know you're at the end of the day,
but I'm gonna try and bring that caffeine
and some of that good morning energy
to to the stream today.
Awesome. I definitely appreciate it. That's for sure.
So
you are a developer advocate at HashiCorp,
and very relevant for today, you were the
one nineteen
Kubernetes release team lead.
Do you wanna add anything to that and
Absolutely.
So so one nineteen, I just kind of,
you know, I'll I'll I'll just kinda jump
in and out of some topics on that
front. But howdy, everyone. My name is Taylor
Dolozol. I'm a senior developer advocate at HashiCorp,
and really, really excited to talk to you
today.
Mostly gonna be covering the 01/19
release and what that experience was like, some
of the fun new features around that, And
then just that whole release process, honestly, David,
was was was a wild experience.
Beforehand, I was working at Walt Disney Studios
on on the SRE team and and and,
you know, helping with all the efforts on
that front. So
the 01/19 release, you know, was one I
I believe the longest release that we've had
thus far
between all of the Kubernetes releases that we've
seen. And so kind of navigating, jumping between
jobs in that,
all the the wild things happening in the
world, you know, it's just been it was
a marathon release is what most of the
team had said around that, which is absolutely
true.
Yeah. Definitely.
So I I wasn't actually aware that this
was the the longest release, but I guess,
you know, there's been a lot of different
factors
in 2020 that may have contributed to that.
I believe you've been under a release team
a while now. Right? How many releases?
Absolutely. So I started on the one fourteen.
It was, I believe, the first release that
I was on.
I saw the shadow survey and then jumped
in and
got started with the communications team. So for
those of you that aren't aware, the release
team,
it is one team, but it's broken into
multiple
different verticals. So we have, you know, one
one grouping. It takes care of communications.
Another one takes care of enhancements,
for example, another documentation,
CI signal. There are different groups that focus
on different things throughout the course of a
release.
And so, typically, the the release teams in,
like, in the, like, lower mid thirties, I
think we had about, if if I'm counting
correctly, I think it was, like, 33, 30
four people on the one nineteen release.
Yeah. I think people watching this will probably
be a little bit surprised that, you know,
with the size of Kubernetes as an open
source project, that there it requires a lot
of people and time and effort to actually
get that release out the door.
It's
it's interesting too because you you know, the
there are different special interest groups within Kubernetes
for, again, you know, for those of you
that aren't aware.
And their, you know, SIG group the special
interest group just for the release handles that
release and then those
those subgroups.
But there are other ones like SIG API
machinery,
SIG docs, you know, and and even more
on that front too. So no shortage of
people to ping or reach out to you
on Slack if you have a question about
a feature that's gonna make it or or
not.
And how have you found the release teams
now? Let's see. If you said one fourteen
is your first, this is your fifth release.
Right? So you've you've experienced a lot of
the role, I guess?
Yeah. So I took I did take off
the the one seventeen
release cycle. So that was and kind of
got to, you know, get a good get
some rest and relaxation
away from that. Because it does it does
take a lot out of you.
But really, really been fun to see how
the group has
evolved in the different ways in which we
go about communicating with one another and seeing,
you know, all of the documentation and handoff
processes get, you know, more and more mature
from release to release.
But and and, honestly, it's it's to in
in on my perspective, my bias, I it
has been a lot easier from release to
release and just kind of that, you know,
talking with people and even just, you know
again, it could've just been
the stars aligning for me with the one
nineteen team, but it just was so
easy to work with everyone. You know, everyone
was just so kind. Everyone was so upbeat.
And because it's an open source project, you
know, that's you're not there's no financial incentive,
hence open source.
Everybody's passionate about the project, and so they're
bringing that passion
to work with them every single day that
you're working on that release. And so that
really you know, that passion really powered this
release. That's where the accentuate the positive title
came from. And, just it was fantastic group
of people to work with and, and everyone
was just, you know, even if there was
a little slippage here or, you know, getting
some done early or late, everybody was just
there and it very much had that family
feel to it, for lack of a better
term.
That's awesome. And I was very curious about
to accentuate the positives, so I'm glad that
we kinda covered that. I think every release
now that I've at least been visible to
or I've been paying attention to. It's like,
these themes are always great, and those come
from the release team leads. Right? You're one
that accentuated the positive here. Right? Oh, absolutely.
Yeah. Just to just to to just trying
to get do a good thing, pay it
forward.
Yeah. Each each of the releases has a
theme that will come with it, which is
chosen by the release lead.
And then, typically, it's well, I I don't
think it's ever been disclosed before the release
has gone live,
but that's usually kept a secret even, you
know
not even told to the release shadows as
well. And so, you know, sometimes they're they
they'll be like, hey. What do you think?
You know, there's that back and forth kind
of workshopping on the idea or, you know,
just kinda double checking to make sure everything
all the the everything lines up. But this
one was definitely intended to be a surprise
and was a lot of fun picking that
out.
That for for for anyone that's seen it,
it's a Animal
Crossing themed
type logo
just very much in the spirit of. And,
you know, that game came out just as
the 01/19 release kicked on and really started
up.
And then, you know, as as we've had
to go through COVID, as we've had to,
you know, just injure endure all these socioeconomic
and other, you know, the natural disasters, just
all these crazy things that we've had happen
to us around the world,
no better time than to focus on one
another, really just being upbeat,
finding out how you can help one another,
and just kind of, you know, it just,
you know, from joining
hands with people and just kinda figuring out
how to meet them where they're at and
just to be, you know, good, kind, uplifting.
And I
I feel we really did that in 01/19,
giving people time as, you know, some weeks
were a lot harder than others, taking a
break from meetings,
you know, definitely around KubeCon. We took a
break there as well, but we really focused
on the community in this release. You know?
If you over overexert
the community and the people working on this
project, you're not gonna have a lot of
people left to to work on the project
if if they're all burnt out. Right? So
it was a lot of fun to to
work with people on that and just really
actively listen and and see what was going
on in the community.
Excellent.
I just popped up the great kind of
artwork there. It's definitely one of my favorite
ones. I think everybody's been a little bit
Animal Crossing that this year, so I thought
it was a very fitting
name, and I think the sentiment that you
just described there as well with the release
is fantastic as well. So great job then.
Thank you. I I don't wanna get this
wrong,
but I believe that shadow applications are open
right now for 01/20.
Is that correct?
That that's correct. I believe that they're closing
up soon. So if you're looking to get
your start on Kubernetes and interacting with the
open source community,
by all means, please please please check that
out. I'll I'll try and find the link.
I'll I'll try and reach retweet that out
later. Try to say that five times fast
and and share that with y'all. But I
do believe that's closing up. So
and if you have any doubts about getting
involved with open source, if you're on the
fence, if you're having that that you know,
if you're if you're undecided on that front,
just do it. I obviously, make sure you
have enough time to do so,
but there are rules for for everyone.
And the biggest the biggest piece of feedback
that I've heard there is that a lot
of people are concerned about,
you know, being judged or just they don't
really feel comfortable sharing their code or their
contributions
with the world. You know, that's a that
is a lot of scrutin scrutiny, but it's
you're working with fantastic people, and they're not
going to, you know, let anything bad happen.
So long as you work with people, you
have that community mindset,
and and that's the goal. That's the intent
that you're walking in with. You're you're not
gonna be disappointed. But by all means, make
sure that you have time to do it.
There there I think when I selected the
communications team, when I started on that with
the Kubernetes release cycles,
that that role fit really well. But, you
know, something like CI or or CI signal,
that one is very involved and it requires
a lot of communication,
between team members. And so you can kind
of pick what works for you, which is
really nice about the open source project.
Yeah. I think, just to kind of touch
on one thing you said there. Like, you
don't even have to write any code, you
don't have to be fearful of writing code.
You can join the release team at the
shadow and and start to experience some of
those different roles and positions and, you know,
never write a single layer of code. I
know I have never written a single layer
of code with the Kubernetes project. So and
it's still a very positive experience. I really
enjoyed the the couple of release teams that
I had as a part of too, and
but you get to meet so many cool
people and just all those interactions.
And and even if you are a little
bit shy and you're curious or on the
fence,
you can just go and lurk in the
second release channel. You can join the mailing
list. There are loads and loads of ways
where you can get the mailer of it
first, but they have to jump straight into
the shadow applications.
But we really do sorry. I had go.
No. That's it's such a great point, David.
I I think that it's such it's most
open source projects, yeah, I I I've felt
like that where it's just like you kinda
jump in. You don't really know what to
expect. Kubernetes, there's a whole bunch of, like,
rule books. There's that shadow process. So you
don't, you know it's you're not you you
don't have to be, like, you know, just
completely in it and you have to know
everything before you do anything. That's the whole
purpose of that shadow program is so that
you can take the time to see how
things work and then ramp up until you're
at a point where you feel comfortable to
take over something in a in a in
a lead capacity. Typically, we've we've advised that,
like, two cycles of being in a shadow
position before getting to that lead position is,
you know, typically how that works out. But,
yeah,
it's it's come come come lurk, come ask
questions,
come enjoy the banter and the conversation. It's
not always about tech. You know, sometimes we
will talk about Animal Crossing.
We'll pop up in a Zoom chat on
a Friday and just kinda talk about life.
You know? Like, it's a it's it it's
it's a family. It's community. It's it's a
lot of fun. It doesn't have to be
there there's equal parts work and play when
it comes to working on Kubernetes, and that's
that makes it a lot of fun.
Yeah. Definitely. Okay.
That's that's great.
We will tweet other links. I'll make sure
they're in the comment section as well in
the YouTube video. The release team is a
great experience. Hopefully, we've done it justice. We
sold it really well there. Feel free to
get involved.
Now we're gonna talk about Kubernetes one nineteen.
So it's
got
it's got some major themes. Like,
we we've got a list here. Do you
want to read through them? Do you wanna
just dive into each one after one? What's
your preferred format here? What would you like
to do? Yeah. So so I'd love to
kind of hit on a lot of major
themes for 01/19.
Then just kind of, you know, if if
they didn't if they weren't on your radar,
we'd just kind of love that opportunity to
put them on your radar.
I I and I'll of course, I'll I'll
point out which ones are my personal favorites,
but we can do we we we can
just jump through them.
So one of the the biggest items
that, happens in 01/19
is increasing the Kubernetes support window to one
year, whereas previously, it was at nine months,
because every three months, typically, you have a
new Kubernetes release. And so that allowed for,
you know, just just two back as soon
as one was one was published.
So now at any given point in time,
starting with 01/19,
there's going to be four that get supported
there. There's a lot of feedback from the
community saying that, you know, nine months is
a is a, you know, sizable amount of
time. However,
we'd like a little bit more time. So
because it is you know, it it does
get a little bit dizzying to have to
upgrade your cluster with every single release that
comes out, and and most teams aren't able
to do that. Some can't do that even
within the nine months period of time. So
we we we hear you, we listen to
you, and and we have one year support.
So that's that's a lot of fun to
see.
Yeah. I I think that's a a change
that's gonna be welcomed by by so many.
You know, Kubernetes has been such an integral
part of of people's production infrastructure.
Even updating
every, you know, three months can be very
daunting, but then getting to the end of
a a supported release,
even even skittier. But I think that extra
bit of buffer, I will really really help
a lot of companies.
It's it's really gonna be fantastic, and I
do hope that, you know, my my selfish
want on on that one with that feature
specifically is
some some of the managed Kubernetes options that
you have. You know, I think that most
of them are are are have one seventeen
supported right now, but I you know, my
personal want is to see that a little
bit closer to
what's, you know, what's gone GA. Like, seeing
one eighteen just a couple months after it
comes out would be great to see, same
with one nineteen
just so that the the community is able
to kind of work with those features, see
see if it's, you know, good fit for
them
and, you know, and so on. But
happy to see that, you know, we have
those manager clusters available as well. And then
for any any of you playing at home,
I'd absolutely recommend checking out the kind project
by the fantastic Ben the elder
that allows you to spin up Kubernetes in
Docker, kind, k I n d. And it
really makes it easy for if you want
to test something, you know, work with the
control plane, or just kind of spin up,
you know, like that. That's how I I
checked and and looked at and started working
with a lot of the one nineteen team
features out of the out of the box
out of the container.
Yeah.
Kinda is definitely the easiest way to start
kicking the tires on some of these features,
especially
even ManyCube as well has really good support
for both of these. So, you know, you
can you can have your shot with any.
I think OneMain team is available on both
pretty much immediately after the release, which it
just makes it so easy for this.
Oh, absolutely. Agree. As far I I I
don't wanna ask you an opinion piece so
early on in our call, but I'm gonna
do it anyway.
There
has been many conversations over the last twelve
months about whether Kubernetes
the release cycle is too fast. Like, and
and corporations and companies are having troubles with
speed up. Is that something that you see
changing maybe in the future? Do you think
it will slow down as the product continues
to mature, or do you think that maturity
will contain anything encourage new contributors and maybe
speed it up?
That's something I have thought a lot about
myself.
And I think that I
personally, I do think that that will become
the case at some point in time and
or, you know, will maybe we'll separate out
into kind of, you know, core features and,
you know, looking at how the process is
set up right now such that you have
you know, you introduce a feature with alpha,
you get feedback
from the community, and you get, you know,
that conversation started, then it moves into beta
after you have, you know, a good backing
there, then finally GA on that front. So
I like that process, but there have been
a lot of conversations that I've been in
both inside of the community and, you know,
in in the end user community.
And there is, you know, it's the stability
is constantly becoming, you know, a a cornerstone
to every release that happens for Kubernetes.
And
being able to you know, there's talks about,
like, can we release bug fixes in a
different, you know
just to release that asynchronously
along with this core functionality,
you know, will things get broken out into,
you know, different types of providers and and
you know, like, having core functionality and then
other different, you know, veins to kind of
feed that into the project. I'm curious to
see if that happens.
And then there was one talk that was
given
at KubeCon San Diego by Tim Pepper and
Steven Augustus, And they talked a lot about,
you know, we don't really have distribution
of Kubernetes out there right now. We ship
the product, but we don't have this distribution
with an opinionated,
like, almost like an OS. Right? We don't
have anything like that. So I think as
time goes on, we'll start to see more,
in both distributions or just methods of delivery
of, you know, what channels are you following
for these features and kind of keeping track
of that. I'm really, really I'd knowing the
Kubernetes community, I know they're gonna they're gonna
do it the right way. They're gonna talk
with the community before anything happens, but I
definitely want them tracking that. That's gonna be
an interesting one for sure.
Right. Keep an eye on that one definitely
then. So we've got twelve months. Everyone should
be happy. They've got the time, and hopefully,
they need to stay on a supported version.
And I think with
you know, I think I love I don't
wanna segue far too much in again. But
your previous role to HashiCorp, you said, was
at Disney. Right? If I remember correctly, you
were an SRE?
Correct. Yeah. Ah, right. Did you run your
own Kubernetes clusters?
So mostly, we focused on just, you know,
Disney is a big place, so so lots
of technologies used.
But,
really, the team that I worked on, we
mostly focused on managed Kubernetes.
We we, you know, we're using EKS
mostly.
Before that,
it it it was a that was a
long road.
We we definitely
identified Kubernetes as the way we want it
to go because it allowed us a common
language to use between our development teams and
our systems teams.
And, you know, it wasn't like every app
wasn't the snowflake or this pet type of
configuration that we'd set up. So we I
liked that we kind of came together as
as, you know, collective teams and decided, you
know, Kubernetes is our future. We started with
the
COPS project
and, you know, tried spinning our own clusters
up that way. But
when you do that, the the open source
community is great, but it makes it harder
for big organizations to, you know, call up
and and ask questions and kind of get
engaged.
Again, community is great, but it doesn't give
you that, like, support contract, and that's what
big enterprises look for.
So we went with Rancher
for a bit and using that as well
as Terraform to stand up. You'll see you'll
you'll see why I'm at HashiCorp soon.
Love Terraform.
But we used Terraform and Rancher to to
stand up and and manage our clusters. So
we were hosting our own control planes and
hosting our own, worker nodes,
and that worked really well for a while.
But, for for anyone that's that's run a
control plane in Kubernetes,
the, ETCD data store,
if you're running that through any abstraction, you
might have some problems from time to time
just as life happens and and comes at
you.
We saw some issues there and just being
able to kind of,
delegate
away all of those ETCD and control plane
problems and scaling issues
to to Amazon was was a very good
move for our teams,
and so we really enjoyed that. But that's
mostly what we would use, and then that
would give us the time. You know, it
was it was,
you know, a little bit behind the current
releases that were out. And so taking that
time to be aware of, you know, like
in 01/16, there were a lot of API
changes.
Taking the time to to work through those
and have the time to adjust was really
nice. And so, again, you know, that's that's
that's why I'm excited about that one year
time cycle for for some of the bigger
end users and people that aren't able to
quickly change everything over just because of the
scale and the size that they're working at.
Yeah. I'll just echo some of your points
there. But every production I teach I've ever
had of a Kubernetes cluster has either been
QTNS or an NCD. So
if you can if you're fortunate enough to
be able to use one of the managed
services, then definitely you should be using that.
And and if not, there's cluster API,
which maybe we'll we'll talk about later.
So
back on track now. Right? I'm I'm I'm
gonna try not to see if I segue
far too much. But the next major theme
on the Kubernetes release blog was the storage
capacity tracking.
What's that?
So I'm gonna lump these to these these
I'm
reading ahead.
So there were a lot of really interesting
features added, you know, in alpha state in
this release. So there is storage capacity tracking,
generic ephemeral volumes,
and CSA volume health monitoring.
All of this really being that, you know,
the expectation
of Kubernetes clusters and and those use cases
were kind of assuming that you had infinite
availability to
to storage
or or just the volumes that you would
actually use to store things then. So just
overall storage. The thought was that that was
infinite.
Now we're able to with the CSI in
place, container storage interface, we have the ability
to be a little bit more intelligent at
looking at, you know, their like, they I'll
just talk about Amazon just because that's where
I've gotten all that's where I have a
lot of experience. So when you take a
look at, you know, EBS volumes versus EFS
versus
kind of all those storage classes that you
have,
you you also have, like, the I nodes
and those have a really fast
local disk storage, the NVIE,
I believe.
And so you're not able to really leverage
that
those volumes
because, you know, you're either dealing with block
storage, you're not really too focused on that
local storage on that machine.
I can't remember which Kubernetes release it was,
but I know that that, you know
once that was kind of pointed out to
the community, they said, hey. Can we just
make use of the disk that we actually
have hosting
on these machines? And so that was added
in. So this allows us to be a
little bit more direct when it comes to
how do we divvy up our, you know,
storage classes and how do we how do
we actually look at storage. So these these
three features have really set the, set us
up, for success in the future for,
identifying,
you know, different types of storage classes instead
of just, you know, throwing an EBS volume
on everything, which is which is quite nice.
The the health monitoring is also really good
too because then you can actually see when
that volume gets mounted to that machine and
so on and so forth. So a little
bit better reporting on that front too, which
is which is quite helpful because, you know,
troubleshooting things in the in the,
troubleshooting things without a lot of information becomes
very difficult.
Oh, yeah. Definitely. That's for sure. So those
three features then are the stories capacity tracking,
which exposes metrics about the utilization
of the different CSI
block devices, etcetera, that we have. I think
the feature you mentioned there,
was that the local provisioner from one
seventeen, I think, that allowed you to actually
access
the bare metal disk?
Like, I remember correctly.
Exactly. Exactly.
And then the the second storage one there
is the generic ephemeral
volumes.
What what does that allow me to do
then from a Kubernetes point of view?
So what that allows you to do is
kind of have, like, a working disk. So
if you have something that you don't want,
you know, that is ephemeral that you don't
need around for a long time,
and you don't want to use your that
local machine's,
you know, volume,
at that point in time, you can kind
of give it a different disk than the
root disk
and then, you know, do whatever operations you
might need to with that and then kinda
throw it away, which is which is kinda
nice. So it's a scratch pad, essentially.
Oh, okay. So if I have a Kubernetes
deployment and I want to leverage some of
the CSI implementations,
but for ephemeral things, I
can't even think like, say, want to do
some of logs, but not under bare metal
test, but on c CSI implementation, then I
could request an ephemeral volume from that provider.
Exactly.
Yeah. And you might have different needs, you
know, if you might need something with higher
IOPS or something like that so you can
get that that quick, you know, burstability,
have it be ephemeral, and then and chuck
it once you're done with it.
Okay. I I I think I get that
now. The
the last part that we were talking about
there was the CSI volume health monitoring. How
does that hook in then to those last
two features, and what what am I getting
on top there?
So what that'll tell you is is so
the, storage capacity tracking, that just kind of
lets you know, like, hey. We're like, you're
really leveraging,
this volume over here. It might not make
sense because you have a lot of disk
pressure. It might, you know, you might not
want to put things over there. The CSI
volume health monitoring, what that really allows you
to do is just kind of get a
sense into the events that are going on.
So if you have, you know, a ceph
cluster, if you have EBS volumes, you can
kind of keep track of
where they're at and how they're doing. So
if you have, you know, a machine go
offline,
you're gonna wanna know about that.
If for for anyone that's used EBS volumes,
those are locked to one availability zone, and
so that kinda makes things difficult when you
want to have, you know, say, a Mongo
DB cluster.
And if that goes down, you know, and
you need to bring it up into another
AZ, you you can't. You have to stay
in that same AZ. You can fix that
with EFS,
which is multi AZ, but
you're you're still gonna wanna have metrics on
getting that rescheduled.
I've I've had nightmares and real life experiences
with EBS volumes and it taking upwards of,
like, four, five minutes to rejoin a machine
and to reconnect.
And so having a little bit more tooling
on, you know, where is this volume, how
is this you know, what's going on, and
having some more error codes to source from
make that a little bit easier experience too
so that you can kind of tune and
and set up the cluster exactly the way
that you'd want when it comes to volumes.
Nice. So one nineteen is a pretty good
release then for as far as stateful applications
and storage goes in.
Oh, absolutely.
Do you have any strong opinions on running
stateful applications on Kubernetes?
I'd so so abs I've I've I've been
there. I I feel the pain when it
comes to supporting, you know, stateful applications.
I've been lucky enough that a lot of
the applications I've worked with have been stateless,
so not too much of a concern.
I've run though, conversely,
I've run Elasticsearch.
I've run MongoDB.
I've I I've played around with running Postgres,
you know. I'd I'd also, like, pull down
RDS or something like that, but definitely work
with Postgres and Helm chart. And it's I
I really like that you're able to do
things like that, but it just is it's,
you know, it's it's something that you have
to think about is are you okay with
that? Because you will run into problems. You
absolutely will no matter how much tooling is
available to you.
Managed services are always easier to a, set
up and to b or b, you know,
have managed because they're managed services.
And you have support. You can call people
and and work with them on that front.
But,
you know, it's it's it's an extra layer
that you really have to think about. You
have to think about if that were to
go down, you have to think about your
backup process. You have to think about and
and do disaster recovery scenarios. So if you're
able to do that, I'm all for it.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
And it's a lot of fun because you
don't normally get that level of insight into
the types of workloads and applications that you
support.
But at the same point in time, that
is a lot of you know, that can
be a very big time sync. And if
you're, you know, if you're a smaller team,
that becomes a little bit harder to do.
So, you know, smaller teams or teams that
support a lot of applications, I'd definitely lean
towards suggesting
a managed service. Otherwise,
stateful sets. Let's let's go. Let's learn some
things because that's that that can be beneficial
too. That's its own, that's its own, payment
kind of kind of plan.
Yeah. I think either you've been extremely lucky
in your career. I'm a bit of a
masochist. But you all the databases you mentioned
there are distributed by default. With MongoDB, you
know, already handles data working across multiple nodes.
Whereas I seem to have been very unlucky
in my career and work with databases that
did not support that. This makes my life
a lot more painful, difficult, and fun. Let's
go with fun.
I I I I maybe at some point
in time, we can we can do some
live coding and get, like, a cockroach DB
cluster set up and something that's supposed to
be easy and support SQL native calls. Maybe
we can we can find some middle ground
between us at some point in time.
Oh, yes. Definitely.
I'd be up for that session for sure.
Because I I mean, I work for a
bare metal company, which means there are no
managed services. So even though I've never worked
with a distributed database previously, I'm now working
for a company that doesn't offer managed services.
So I maybe it's masochism as my
okay. So volumes are cool. I really love
that. I think anything that makes stateful applications
in Kubernetes easier for people to consume is
fantastic.
The the next one on this list that
we have shocked me a little bit, and
I don't know if I'm just being really
naive or not.
Angus graduates to general availability.
Was that not generally available?
Right? That's I'd I'm not kidding you despite
being, you know, this true, you know, taxicab
confession.
Yeah. I I thought the same thing walking
into the 01/19 release. I I had had
a double take the first time I saw
it. I like, wait a minute. What? It
was a a Gmail beta, you know, type
so we're getting rid of the beta. It's
like, wait a minute. That was beta type
moment for sure.
When I I can't remember the and and
forgive me. You know, I'm still still booting
up with some caffeine here, but
I can't remember which Kubernetes enhancement proposal it
was. But there was one about kind of
reevaluating
and looking at that alpha beta GA type
classifications
because
we would have the situation where
something would go into it's a chicken and
egg problem. When you have something go into
alpha, you've got it into Kubernetes. That's fantastic.
But most of the time, it's hidden behind
the feature flag that you'll have to enable
or, you know, pass the cubelet and then
that will get supported.
And with anything alpha, you know, it doesn't
really scream production,
you know, nor should you in in many
cases unless you're just you you're knowingly you've
accepted the risks and you're testing out a
new feature. Never turn on alpha. That's my
my recommendation. I think the any lawyer is
going to back that up too.
But when so
we get into this situation where all of
these new alpha features are really cool. Like,
look at the ones that we're talking about.
They sound fantastic.
But if you don't have that beta or
higher type of certainty that it's actually going
to go live at some point in time,
you you you you don't have a lot
of certainty. And that's what we like when
we're working with infrastructure.
So
the the language was changed there and just
kind of that that process because a lot
of people would come forward and say, hey.
I have this thing in alpha. Can we
just move it to beta? Because that will
get people to use it. People are, you
know, typically
not
jumping to use alpha features. So that makes
it hard to move to that beta stage.
Even if there is that level of interest,
it can still be pretty difficult.
So the language and just kind of that
overall process was changed. Again, I can't remember
the cap that that that one was around,
but that's why the ingress, you know, working
as it was,
It just needed some final things to push
it across the finish line so that we
could deem it as stable in GA and
then, you know, start start working with the
community and more features. So that's that's one
I'm pretty
excited about. It's one of my personal favorites
along with the longer support time is the
is the Ingress finally moves to GA. Woo.
Yeah. I think it's one of those
one of those things that
because
I'm gonna get this wrong. We are just
so conditioned,
I feel, as users of Kubernetes to v
one beta one. That to me, that was
GA, like, because we just had all those
APIs for so long. And, of course, now
we've got v one, but I just always
assumed that ingress was one of those one
of those objects. It was just available. I
mean, every Kubernetes cluster I've had for years
now has used ingress. And I never once
thought for a second it was something that
was on beta.
So
Same. And it works so well. It's it's
worked so well. So it's you know, just
like Gmail did for eleven years, I think
it was, before it went GA. You know?
It's Ingress did did everything you needed it
to.
Yeah.
At at least yeah. You're right. It's always
work. So it's fine. It's good.
And I think yeah. It's it's
it's it's nice for people to understand how
that new feature thing works from KEP to
alpha to beta and to to GA. And
I think you can just cover that in
a complete journey of a KEP, which is
nice and cool.
And and go visit the GA, you can
start using it, I guess, you know, if
you weren't going.
I think that that they changed the
the namespace as well. Was that the release
or the previous one? I can't remember now.
But
I think that's when I first realized that
things weren't as I always expect them to
be.
Cool.
So we've got two
more we got three more, but there's two
more I think we're probably gonna group together
now. The next two major themes are structured
logging and the keylog methods.
What are those?
So structured logging is going to be fantastic
because
well, it is.
It's really fantastic because it allows us now
we to to get standard logs out of
Kubernetes.
We could do things with standard out and
standard error,
and,
you know, that made it made it easy
when we had a log aggregation layer in
our stack, like Elastic searcher or something else.
And then, you know but it did become
kind of a pain point when we started
indexing those logs and because you were never
really you got logs, but they just weren't
in, you know, a similar format. So that
indexing became difficult and then sourcing what data
you actually needed to see became difficult.
That, you know, mutating those logs
downstream before you put them into your login
cluster, that that becomes an issue. So finally,
you know,
the the there's there's a feature now where
we actually have everything time stamped
and then you have, like, a logical
standard out and standard error to actually source
from.
There's we'll we'll kinda go through a a
quick demo on that one in here in
a little bit, but you'll just be able
to see those lines are are now different
because they start with that time stamp and
it's just in the standard format. So even
if you, you know, advise your teams to
log in JSON or anything else, you're if
you're just doing, you know, line by line
type of logging, that's going to be consistent
now and you don't need to worry so
much about that or making crazy reg regular
expressions
to deal that and to capture those, you
know. I'm sure
everyone agrees with me that there's better time
better better time spent than on regular expressions.
Yeah. Apologies to those of you that really
enjoy it.
I have wasted so much of my life
writing regex and grok parsers for Logstash and
Telegraph and all these other tools, but just
the and it's JSON is such
it just makes everything so much easier. It's
I think the way that we consume all
of these logs and like I said, we're
gonna do a demo in a few minutes.
People will hopefully just see right away the
power that we get, the flexibility we're gonna
get from this approach.
I I had the spoilers. I was not
able to get the the the thing I
really like, I just haven't been able to
replicate on that front with the logging is
that output in JSON. But so I'll show
you what, you know, just just regular
standard out and error looks like. But being
able to once you're able to tap into
that JSON, this feature, you know, both those
features are in alpha now. But being able
to work with that and see that get
to GA is so exciting because,
you know, like like David said, lost years
of my life. And there's I I don't
see any right now, but at least, like,
15 gray hairs that have that will be
coming out from a regular expressions one, I'm
sure.
Yeah. And I I don't wanna
make any naive assumptions, but, you know, it's
like it's more formality, right, for such a
log in to colonize an alpha just because
it's a new feature. I don't really see
what would hold out from graduating to beta
and stable other than formality of possession.
Exactly.
It's just kinda that that steep time that,
you know, just time to work with the
community. And then that new KLOG method they've
given, you know, the community the the project
that with that feature, you're able to kind
of take your time and then kind of
lean everything over into that new logging library
such that you can really leverage it,
you know, despite despite what's what's coming out
of the logs as it is right now.
Sweet. Awesome. I'm looking forward to playing with
that. Alright. We've got one more thing on
our super duper list, which is
the Kubelet client
CLS certificate rotation.
So this one is really cool.
Really should have made my list. I don't
know why I haven't talked more about it.
But
I
think mostly because it's it's been something that
we've been used to and that has kind
of been done, you know, behind the scenes.
And that edit that is the the Kubelet
client TLS certificate rotation.
So that that did happen in the past,
but that was happening within the outside of
the cluster mechanism.
So with this feature that's gone GA,
that finally is brought into the cluster
so that as needed, the control plane can
kind of roll those client certificates,
and it's just not something that you need
to think about. So when the Kubelet calls
in and it needs that new one, it's
it's just a lot more seamless. You reduce
that level of latency,
and, and, you know, everything just works trademark.
There you heard it from Taylor himself. Everything
is just going to work.
Just got back to go. See you later.
So
so what we've covered I'm just sharing my
screen here. It's pretty much the majority of
this article,
which is the release article
that just tells you what's new. At the
bottom, we do have a couple of things
that we haven't touched on,
and some of them are quite important. So
the first one is is that the set
comp integration has now graduated to stable.
Assuming things go well, we will take a
look at that and how that works, I'm
moving away from the old annotation approach to
the new actual pod spec level stuff, which
is really cool.
And I'm not sure if there's anything else
here that you wanna quickly run over, like
the
run multiple schedule and profiles. I mean, that
sounds kind of important,
but I don't think I fully understand it.
Is that something you're comfortable talking about?
I think with most of these so I'm
still honestly, I'm still working through a lot
of these myself and just kind of trying
to find, you know I'm
having a lot of moments
after
after the release, getting to kind of see
these three things worked through, see the tests
that, you know, they've been put through in
Pro.
But it it's still working quite a quite
a few of these and and and how
they apply to my workloads. But yeah. So
none none that I could talk to you
right now with the TLBR,
but very excited too.
Yeah. Well, I mean, all of these are
links to the caps and issues so people
can obviously go if if anything there makes
you peaks your interest, then feel free to
go click and take a look at it.
The other thing we are gonna take a
look at today, however, is the immutable secrets
and conflict maps, which hopefully we can get
that working and show you how cool that
is or painful depending on your prerogative.
And another one I really like, which is
less of a major change, but I think
it's been graduating over the last couple of
releases, is the North Topology Manager, which actually
allows you to do Rawkode data center where
service reading, which is really, really cool too.
And maybe it's something that we will touch
on
another day.
Okay. I think it's time to get
hands on.
You feeling brave?
Always.
Alright. So I'm not sure if I'm not
sure if that's a good thing or a
character flaw, but
It's a good thing. It's a good thing.
Okay. So we're gonna do the immutable secrets
and contact maps, seccomp GA, and structured logging.
Do you have a preference of where you
would like to start?
I can kick it off with yeah. So
if if if you wouldn't mind grabbing the
immutable secrets and seccomp, I I I can
kick it off kinda easy breezy with some
structured logging for sure.
Alright. Let's do it.
Cool. Let me share my screen
and click the right buttons, and then we
should
be
there.
Alright. So everyone should see my
terminal. Let me get that at a decent
size for everyone.
So
so I have spun up actually, let me
let me get rid of this.
So I'd
say like, I'm gonna delete things with you
live.
Okay. So
the kind project that I talked about a
little bit earlier is really fantastic because it
allows for you to
spin up a local Kubernetes cluster. So I'm
actually gonna cat out this this configuration.
So I was working a little bit earlier
with the seccomp,
which I've, you know, happily happily
hot potatoed
for the David for
for one of our next demos. But you
can see that you're I'm able to specify
the 01/19 release here. And then working with
some of those those profiles, you can see
that there are different arguments and and ways
in which you can define this,
when you're spinning up your your Kubernetes cluster.
Please note that up here in the role,
that's actually going to be the different machines,
you know, the virtual machines here that I'm
going to be spinning up and working with.
So huge thank you to the the team
that manages kind.
It's it really makes it easy when you're
working with, with local workloads,
in addition to, you know, things like mini
cube and Docker for Mac, Windows, Linux, and
spinning up those Kubernetes cluster. But the benefit
here is that it makes it very easy
to go ahead and and grab the the
latest version there. So so I've deleted that
out. I'm gonna do kind,
and let's create
a cluster.
Also, like the tooling just because it's, you
know, all the command line items just make
a lot of sense.
I also do very much like the emojis.
You can see here is an image.
You got machines here with the with the
nodes, the package. I really like that.
As you configuration,
you gotta scroll.
Control plane, you have game controller. Fantastic.
But I think I think I figured out
most of these, but I'm not a %
sure. But we'll see we'll see how well
my my skills of relation are as we
go through this. But the good thing about
this too is that it doesn't really take
that much time.
I think it's the control plane step, and
when it joins the worker nodes to that
control plane, that's, like, when you're waiting for
twenty, thirty seconds. It's it's typically not that
long. So, hopefully, you don't have to eat
my shoe,
after after,
saying that. But, so, yeah, you have,
CNI, storage class. This is working on. It
takes just a little bit of time.
But then you're and then it writes that
cube config,
to your local file system,
and you don't need to worry about that
either. So once this once this is done,
I'll kinda just show you that we have
a a working cluster, and then I'm just
gonna tail the logs to cube d or,
core DNS to to show you what those
standard logs look like.
Cool.
So we have a cluster.
Let me
so I a couple things for those of
you following along at home. I've aliased the
cube control just to k. So if you
see me typing k, I'll I might bounce
back and forth depending on the commands, but
that's that's my alias and setup.
I also use two two tools.
One is cube context
and cube namespace, and that just makes it
a little bit easier for me to switch
between clusters
because, you know, I'll typically manage quite a
few. So if we go ahead and we
take a look at the nodes,
kind switches over that context to the cluster
that you just spun up so you don't
need to switch to it, which is kinda
nice. So we can see that we have
four machines here. One is the control plane,
and then we have these worker machines here.
If I jump into
the
oops.
I jump into cube system here, make it
a little bit easier for me to get
these pods and see what's up. So we
can see we have our whole control plane
here
and say, I want to go ahead and
take a look at this I don't want
to define that. Get out of
I want to take a look at the
logs here and
follow along.
We can see that, you know, here are
some of the errors. That's not so hot,
but, you know, I'm I'm assuming everything's working
working now. We can see that we have
time stamps, and then we have these, you
know, just the regular body of the message.
Beforehand, you know, you would get the separate
pieces of information
and data, but if we let's take a
look at another pod. Let's take a look
at
let's take a look at this one.
But you can see here, you know, now
everything is standard in the fact that we
can always rely on that timestamp being first
and then getting that that, you know, downstream
data in the body of that message later.
Again, I apologize. I was not able to
get the, the JSON view,
up for for this. I think there's a
couple, flags I needed to double check and
take a look at my setup. But you
are able to export this as JSON if
you specify the right commands,
and that is going to be that's gonna
obviously be a lot easier to kind of
look through and then filter on as you're
try trying to tail logs and things like
that. So really excited to see how this
evolves over time and as we're able to,
you know, filter on, like, I only want
to see error logs and,
you know, the biggest one being that it's
so difficult to kind of link together if
you have a deployment that's three pods to
kind of tile those logs together so that
you get a comprehensive view as to what's
going on without having having to stand up
your own login cluster. So that's that's structured
logging.
Nice. And because I am feeling brave
and I have been working on the JSON
stuff, I'm going to get that go.
So
and
I'll I'm using many cube instead of cane.
Oh, and I I will
I'm not feeling good because I can't even
spell. I will feel brave in the lead
night.
Yes. And
so the way this would work,
I feel particularly
brave. What up?
Let's jump over here. So I have a
I guess it's maybe too brave, but I've
been working on a branch of many cubes
to make this a bit easier. So
let's let's look at what this would work.
Let's let's look at how this would work
normally. So is that bigger? Hold on. There
we go. So many kubelers to pass dash
dash extra config, which allows you to specify
extra parameters that can go to each of
the Kubernetes components.
But what I could do here is I
can say that I wanna pass something to
the kubelet, and the key that I wanna
modify is gonna be the logging format.
And I can specify that JSON like so.
Unfortunately,
I I could do that for every component.
Requires doing this and saying, hey. Let's do
the scheduler too.
And then that have to do what else?
That would be the API server. That would
be the proxy. That would be core DNS.
Like, that lane would get super painful.
And I'm a very lazy developer. So
what I started doing with this ability where
we could just specify dash dash login format
equals JSON, and you'll see that I've added
some crappy characters to the end because
I actually don't know how to write tests
for many cubes. I wanted to make sure
it didn't work as well,
and that was the way that I did
it. So you can see here
that it just says, hey. This is not
a supported login format. So let's just do
that again with JSON.
Many cubes should take
I mean, I look bad, but I'm I'm
gonna assume it's gonna be okay.
It should just take oh, it's not okay.
It's there to delete.
Maybe I had one cluster and a half
set up state there.
If that doesn't work, was gonna be able
to wait. But it should just take roughly
about one minute, maybe a little bit less,
get us a working note.
And what we'll see following on but we
can already see the parameters being added now
to the different components, so schedule, the kubelet,
the controller manager, and the API server.
And we should be able to pull out
those logs, much missing by the tail of
that, only ours will be in adjacent representation.
The cool thing about that is it's gonna
be really easy for that to be parsed
by
long stash, elastic search, telegraph, vector, whatever tooling
you have in your setup.
Cool. It didn't crash this thing, so I'm
happy.
So if I run,
I do not have the fancy tool like
you do, cube namespace.
But I could do key dash n cube
system, and I'm gonna pull out the API
server logs. And when I do that,
it's not JSON.
So that's my I knew it was different.
That just means that my fork didn't work.
So let's just quickly do this the all
the way there, and I'll just do the
API server.
That was really unfortunate. I was so confident.
Was there.
I swear it's a it's as soon as
you do a live demo, that's a there's
something that happens. You lose your magical powers.
Don't know what it is, but, yeah, being
alone, you know, and just that solitude, that
focus
really
really brings it out of the demo.
Yeah. I don't know what I did wrong
there because I have tested this.
And I've told her on the API server,
and I did enable it on the API
server. Oh, well, it doesn't matter. So
what I did there is API server. Now
if this doesn't work again,
that means the API server just ignored it.
Oh, it did. Okay.
So you can see here,
we now actually have JSON for every single
line. And and if I just pick up
on a keynote page for j q
we
have JSON. It's easy to parse. I can
use other tools with it.
Much good.
That's it. A structured login is not one
of those things that has a substantial amount
of change. I think most of the changes
came
from you reusing the different key log methods
within the instrumentation.
But nice. Good.
I'm not gonna ask script anymore. It's just
I'm not brave. I'm not not at half
past six on a Monday.
Okay. So structured logging. Very cool. We like
it. We're looking forward to see tools, take
advantage of them, and store logs with
good debugging stuff.
What did we say was next?
What
is next? I think it was the I'm
not sure if you wanna save the oh,
this this one should be pretty easy. Immutable
secrets and config maps.
Yes. Right. Okay.
So
at pop open
Code
and let's deploy
I'm not gonna do We're doing a config
map.
And we'll call this
RTFM,
and we can just have any arbitrary value
like so.
I guess we should just show
and maybe talk about how this works currently
without making any modification because I don't think
people really understand what
happens
and why this is a bit of a
pain point. So
if we do apply
this,
then we can do a two p I'm
in bash, and then I'm not getting my
Elliot.
Config map
r t f m.
If I modify this value in fact, I
didn't show the value.
You can see here, key is 1545.
Now if I change this and reapply it,
I run git, we have this updated value.
That could be considered
good or bad depending
on what you're doing with your Kubernetes cluster.
So I'll speak from my own experience, and
then maybe you wanna chip in with how
you feel. I don't think of
I I I don't know if we both
have the same opinion or not. But there's
this weird thing that everyone in their Kubernetes
journey has to deal with at some point,
and that's when you make a modification to
a contact map. You have running pods inside
of your cluster,
and there's actually no notification or event that
tells that pod that it needs to restart
because the configuration changed.
And I see it's so common that there
are a lot of helm charts now that
will actually put an annotation on the pod
spec with the SHA of the config to
force that thing change.
But the other school bus thought this is
the config maps shouldn't change anyway and that
you should always deploy a new config map
and then we have a new deployment that
consumes it or an updated deployment that consumes
it. Is that kind of a name of
your experience as well?
Oh, absolutely. It's it's it's when you have
something especially when you follow, like, you know,
a GitOps type methodology
where
what you see in that repository or, like,
when you set up a cluster and app
something,
you you have to have in my opinion,
you have to have something that is static
so that you can reproduce it. If you
have a config map that's mutating or changing,
secrets that are mutating or changing, you don't
get that level of certainty.
And so that makes it kind of difficult
to troubleshoot, to reproduce
issues that happen,
things of that nature. And this also, say
this were, you know, a Bitcoin wallet, and,
and I found out what David's was, I
could quickly change that. And then, you know,
we could we could use, his money instead
of mine, and you you wouldn't want that,
would you?
No.
So
I guess yeah. And just to kind of
really cement why this was a problem is
that different
if some of your pods in your deployment,
if you get 20 pods and some of
them restart, they could be consuming an older
version of the config.
Some could be modifying a new version. And
if you've actually applied three, four, or five
changes to your contract map for whatever crazy
thing you're doing, all of your pods could,
in theory, be running a different configuration.
Really weird.
We had a comment. I think someone noticed
the error with my, by the way. It
was that I possibly wasn't actually using my
locally compelled one, but
I'm not gonna back to it. I'll hopefully
get that pull request merged and everyone else
can
seal that.
So one nineteen gives us this new thing,
and it should
I'm gonna say it should be as simple
as adding a new key to the config
map that says this is immutable.
K. So we now have that configured. If
I just pull it back down you know,
I've never actually modified an mutable conflict map
to be immutable. And so let's let's see
if this breaks or not. But you can
see here, we have the value
immutable true, and the value is 678.
Now if I've done this correctly and I
have to say that this should now be
a b 1 2 3,
when I apply this, we should get another
message that says you cannot modify this conflict.
It worked.
Yes.
So it's it's one of those really small
changes.
The API surface is really small, what mutable
true, and it's done. But I think the
quality of life of people that are consuming
and using Kubernetes and the deterministic
nature of now that a deployment of a
conflict map will always be in sync is
really, really important to people. At least, I
I think that would be a very welcomed
addition to the API for sure.
Absolutely agree. And and secrets are just as
easy too. All you need to add is
that immutable true flag,
and you're good to go. But definitely agree
with David on that front. It's e even
figuring out, you know, what what is tech
what is a secret in Kubernetes,
what is, you know, worthy of putting into
ConfigMap.
And at the end of the day, that's
typically, like, anything you're okay with seeing in
plain text
is usually a pretty good smell smell test,
you know, before you actually put it in
there as well. So, you know, credit card's
not a good config map entry to put
in there.
No. Alright.
We got two follow ups in the chat
there. So the first one being
another big issue is if you have a
config map managed in a separate repository, it's
a pain because of the Kubernetes native event.
Yeah. So that's just reaffirming that deployment situation.
And I think the use case here
is
if you've got, like, a platform GitOps repository
that provides those environment information and then your
applications are deployed separately,
there's no way to connect the dots between
that conflict map changing and what's in the
cluster. Yeah. It's a a huge problem.
Immutable conflict maps, just remove that because you
always have to deploy a new one and
update the surrounding thing. So, yeah, I think
it's cool.
The other question was,
can we delete
can we delete an immutable config map?
Yes.
He says confidently.
I did do this earlier, so it's gone.
And there's nothing there to stop you deleting
that. There's no protections from
there's there's nothing there to stop you deleting
something that's gonna be consumed by it. So,
yeah, if that's a challenge, you're gonna end
up with pods and a fail to restart
container create loop if you delete one that
is needed.
But at least you can be sure the
content's all very good.
Yes. Absolutely.
There there was one edit too because
even though, like, we had said before, David
pointed out the fact that, yeah, when you
change a config map, that doesn't automatically restart
all of your pods, you know, unless you
have some, you know, some some out of
band tooling that that handles that. But Kubernetes
native does not give you that that type
of experience.
However,
Kubernetes keeps track of, you know, hey. This
config map was updated. Right? Because it has
to store that state.
And so when you market as immutable,
Kubernetes gets that very, you know and and
I I believe in most cases, very small
performance gain where it doesn't keep checking to
see if that config map has been updated
because it knows it can't be. So there's
there's also that, like, hidden benefit as well.
You know, at the end of the day,
I'm not sure how much how much performance
it's going to net you, but just something
that's cool. Might be a good trivia question
or something to pay attention to with the
all the cloud trivia that that that we've
seen this. Yeah. So that that's a really
actually good point because
what you've just said has now put in
a bit of ambiguity into the problem domain
that I was mentioning. So I think we
should quick let's just clear this up.
Now the contact maps are and I if
I get this wrong, please correct me. When
they're exposed as environment variables or fails, well,
fails and environment variables are updated within the
pod. The challenge is the process running normally
doesn't know to take advantage of the reload,
which why you end up with multiple processes
consuming old information.
It's not that Kubernetes doesn't
update the file or the environment there. That's
right. Yeah.
Exactly. Exact.
Cool. And I think what we should just
do now is show off one other thing
because I'm sure there'll be a question on
it later. But what if I deploy this
as immutable and want to make it mutable?
I'm just gonna say unimmutable,
and I would have just left it like
that.
So
we now have an immutable conflict map. And
if I remember correctly, you cannot then make
it mutable. This will not work.
Okay. So if you make a conflict map
immutable, there is no undoing it to do
it online or hot updates.
You always have to create a new config
map.
But I can't do it, so let's get
rid of it.
That reminds me of Slack
channels, how you can make it private, but
you can't then turn a private channel back
into a public one, which also makes sense.
Yeah. I guess so. Yeah.
I don't think there's anything else to cover
on the immutability here. I think we've pretty
much covered every potential edge case and question.
So
that means we have to move on to
the difficult bit. So
we're gonna talk about the let's close that.
The promotion
of the SET Comp API.
Was the journal available? Yeah. I think it
was. Yes.
So I cheated.
I
have downloaded a seccomp profile. I am not
brave enough to try and put that together
during a livestream.
And this is for NGINX. What is really
cool
is if you deploy the set comp operator,
this profile is actually provided for you. I'm
not going to show the set pump operator
today. There's a stream on that last week.
Feel free to check it out. What we're
gonna look at today is just the raw
Kubernetes aspect of it working with the API
directly.
So what does that mean we need? We
need a deployment.
I see that's Versus code extension where you
never have to actually type the YAML. I
don't even know if I could type the
deployment YAML anymore.
Wow. So I'm just noticing I need to
add that and save myself hours of time.
Thank you, Dave. Yeah.
So that's the the resources.
I don't need the port, but I'm just
because it'll annoy me, I'll add the port.
Now what happens here is I can deploy
this engine x resource.
It's like any normal resource.
It's a minute. Okay. Nothing wrong.
Oh, I'm applying the JSON
because I called it deployment. There we go.
Which means I can now do
quick control, get parts.
Let's just get that second. It's gonna be
pulling down the NGINX image.
Running on a lot. Of course, it's running.
And now I could do exec
NGINX,
not my real shell, so I can't get
all complete.
And let's see then the next container, and
I can drop back in.
Nothing exciting there. All standard stuff.
However,
there is a certain attack vector
without specifying a set comp profile,
and that is if a malicious actor, sometimes
when they just to get within the process,
can they execute commands that we do not
want them to execute? Like, me exit me
getting inside of a a pod seems harmless,
but, you know, the ability to get inside
of that namespace could be potentially dangerous. Right?
So we can use the setcom profile
here,
which lets all of the syscalls that NGINX
is expected to make
and restricts it.
So what we have to do is copy
this,
and then if I do many qb s
s h so you have to be on
each of the hosts or the nodes, and
you have to put in a file.
I'm gonna have to
on RIP,
and we're gonna add a directory to the
kubelet configuration.
So that is where all the kubelet conflict
lives. We can create a new deck,
create a new directory
called seccomp
profiles,
and need to do an app update and
install them because I'm not gonna have it.
I just realized.
Magic
stuff happens.
I'm my Internet is not too bad.
And we can go ahead and set seccomp
profiles.
Now from here, I can create nginx
dot JSON,
paste that,
and leave it alone.
So this would obviously be part of your
configuration management
setup. You just have Terraform,
write this file, or SaltStack, or Puppet, whatever
you're using. Put all of your profiles into
a single location on each of your workers
so they can be considered by the pods.
Or you can use the second operator, which
does all that work. Anyway,
now we wanna restrict the Cisco's engine x
can make. And to do that, these changes
to the API leverage the security contact API.
So this already exists,
allows you to do things like what?
Force the UID, the GID. I think there's
a few other things.
But now we can specify
second profile,
and we have a type.
So
this is where I'm gonna start getting into
territory that I'm not entirely comfortable with, but
I'll try and remember it.
There are
local host types
and container runtime type.
Run time
I
think it's runtime default.
The documentation is gonna have that covered.
But this is a profile that ships with
your CRI implementation,
which tries to
remove some of the more dangerous syscalls,
like, privilege escalation and such,
but it's not really specific to applications you're
gonna run. For that, we have to tell
it to use a local host,
which is gonna use the profiles in the
directory we just provisioned,
and then we can tell it which profile
we want to use.
Assuming I've not messed this up, which is
extremely likely,
I should be able to do profiles engine
x dot JSON,
and that path
is just
profiles here, the directory that I created, and
the engine x dot JSON here.
We
can apply that. So I drop out my
mini cube SSH.
It will do a cube control apply
and redo the deployment.
No. We won't.
Oh, drop out of Brit, drop out of
Minikube. Now I can do it.
Okay.
But if I've not messed this up, I
should be able to run get pods and
see the pods running.
Good.
And we can confirm
that it has
and what we expect. So describe pods,
pod name,
and then we'll describe for
account.
You can see here,
we are running this NGINX
profile.
And what that means is I'm gonna use
a pod name again. As I try and
exec and save at this,
fails. Good.
So what happened there
is
this test call
get p
process group, I think that is the syscall,
failed because our set pump profile doesn't allow
engine x to run that syscall, and I
can no longer get in a container.
The good thing about that is if someone
were able to exploit an NGINX
vulnerability
or CVE
to get inside of that container, the chances
of them being able to execute any commands
that would potentially allow them to get back
then to the host should hopefully be not
done by it.
Hopefully.
I think that's it. Like,
the API surface is nice and small. Unfortunately,
writing the second profile is really difficult.
So the Google will try and find ones
that other people have written. And but the
application from a Kubernetes point of view could
not be simpler.
So, you know, a couple of lines on
the security context and you're good to go.
Is there anything
you wanna add to that?
No. I think just very much agreeing with
you that that that writing a seccomp profile
is is, you know, at least right now,
difficult. I definitely want to learn more on
that front as well. I think I'd feel
more comfortable writing an autobiography before a seccomp
profile as it stands today. But
no. Absolutely. It's one nineteen's fun. Go check
it out. If you have any questions about
features, you know, please feel free to reach
out. If there's any, you know, demos or
or, you know, you feel like there's a
blog entry that's needed or tutorials, things like
that, hit us up. You know? And it's
it's kinda fun to see what people are
using, to talk through those work streams and
those workflows, and just get a sense as
as to what everybody's interested in. Let's let's
have a conversation.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much for joining
me today. This is is really good to
just kinda sit down and go through some
of the new features, you know, understand how
they work and and dig in some a
little bit more. So
thank you. I'm
good.
Thanks for having me. No. This was a
blast.
Hope you all have a wonderful rest of
your Monday. And, yeah, thanks thanks for hanging
out with us. Alright. Thanks again, Taylor. I'll
speak to you soon. Bye, all. Thank you,
Nikki.